hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine torten wird
heute gibt es endlich mal wieder ein
typisches rezept von mir sonst sicher
fehler von euch bereits gewünscht und
ich hab mir jetzt gedacht ich mache
heute porsche und zwar heißen die karte
kann man heißt so viel wie vielschichtig
und das bezeichnet einfach diese kleine
brötchen gebacken werde und zwar ist es
wie so eine art vereinfachter
blätterteig indem man einfach die teig
schichten übereinander legt mit etwas
butter dazwischen und die gehen dann
später wieso im blätterteig richtig
schönen blick auf diese porsche werde
ich heute mit einer kartoffel füllung
füllen
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch gerade
jetzt zur herbstzeit mit einer kürbis
füllung fühlen also starter kartoffel
nehmt ihr dann einfach kürbis oder ihr
neben ganz normal käse oder eine
hackfleisch bildung
ich werde euch jetzt erst einmal zeigen
wie man den teig macht und zeigt euch
dann wie es weitergeht
dafür braucht ihr 600 gramm mehl 250
milliliter milch die habe ich jetzt warm
gemacht
120 gramm öl 1 1 esslöffel zucker einen
teelöffel salz und einen halben würfel
hefe oder eine packung trockenhefe ich
habe jetzt bereits die hefe in der milch
aufgelöst hat da auf den zucker mit rein
gegeben damit sie eben schon ein
bisschen aufgehen kann und werde jetzt
den teig weiterverarbeiten
danach könnt ihr dann einfach alle
zutaten zusammen in euren thermomix
geben oder eben per hand verkneten oder
mit einer anderen küchenmaschine da noch
salz rein das sei dann eben milch hefe
und zucker
das lässt sich kurz verrühren bevor das
öl mit reinkommt das gebe ich dann hier
durch die deckel öffnung jetzt zwei
minuten zwei minuten 30 besser und dann
auf knet stufe so sieht der teig doch
aus den hole ich hier kurz raus nebenher
küchenlinie die kartoffel die ich dann
gleich ausbildung verarbeiten werde
erklärt ich jetzt einmal kurz durch dann
kommt ein kleines bisschen öl in einer
schüssel
da kommt die zeit kugel rein dann willst
du abgedeckt und so las ich den teig
jetzt an einem warmen ort etwa einer
halben stunde bis eine stunde gehen bis
es sich deutlich vergrößert hat
in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr jetzt
schon einmal die führung herstellen dazu
verwende ich jetzt wie gesagt meine
kartoffeln aber ihr könnt natürlich auch
eine andere füllung nehmen und die
kartoffel führung geht ganz einfach das
mache ich auch er so nach augenmaß
also da habe ich jetzt kein genaues
rezept für euch ich habe jetzt etwa fünf
kartoffel genommen
und weil es das einfach kürzen und wird
etwas zwiebel verfeinern und dann gehts
auch gleich schon weiter meine
kartoffeln sind jetzt schön weich
gekocht die habe ich jetzt kalt
abgeschreckt und werde es ja einmal
fällen dann werde ich die kartoffeln
jetzt einmal hier einreiben
dann wird hier jetzt noch die zwiebel
reingeschrieben ich habe jetzt so eine
große aber ich werde jetzt glaube ich
nur die hälfte frei machen die reifen
wähle dann die zwiebel darin habt könnt
ihr schon dass gewürze zugeben ich gebe
jetzt etwas cayennepfeffer reihen für
den schwerter natürlich etwas salz wenn
mir kommt noch paprikapulver eine
frische kräuter habt könnt ihr gerne
petersilie oregano und so weiter rein
machen ich habe dir jetzt nicht deswegen
nämlich kräuter der provence gut
durchrühren ich gebe es noch ein
bisschen frischem basilikum dazu den
schneide ich jetzt einfach mit der
schere rein und dann ist die füllung
fertig mein tag ich jetzt schon
aufgegangen denn bis jetzt portioniert
werden
das wird ja schon deutlich seine aus
blätterteig gemacht in verschiedenen
schichten
deswegen habe ich mir ja auch schon die
butter vorbereitet und geschmolzen
aber jetzt gehe ich erstmal den teig den
halb wie ich mir jetzt einmal und diese
hälften müssen jeweils im sex
gleichgroße stücke geteilt werden
also nochmal halbieren am besten und
dann die in drei stücke teilen
jetzt arbeite ich absichtlich mit der
ist silikon matte die habe ich mir mal
wo gekauft
hier hat man nämlich ganz schön so ringe
und das sieht man wie groß man dann
auszurollen kann oder muss und das werde
ich jetzt nämlich ihr müsst jetzt
nämlich immer sechs teigstücke ausrollen
dann kommt etwas zerlassene butter
dazwischen dann werden sie übereinander
gelegt und später eben noch mal ganz
dünn ausgerollt einmal ich stolz hier
wie es geht
20 cm groß aus dann lege ich mir das zur
seite so lange es andere treibstoffe und
macht das gleiche damit
das muss aber nicht 100% ganz genau sein
nehmt euch dann einfach mit pinsel und
bestreicht und teilstück mit etwas
butter überall damit vernetzen
dann kommt das nächste stück drauf und
das wiederholt ihr jetzt so lange bis
ihr sechs teilstücke übereinander haupt
dann nehmen wir euch einen teller und
packt das ganze päckchen hier drauf die
auch noch schöne an stücken von der
rückseite und muss noch mal einen
kühlschrank gestik mutter fest ich das
mache ich jetzt mit denen hier auch und
dann empfehlen wir uns gleich wieder bei
meinem teil jetzt schon fest geworden
dann nehme ich mir jetzt das erste
päckchen bestäubt mit etwas mehl auch
auf der unterseite und dann rollte das
ist schön hinaus und so entstehen dann
diese dünnen schichten
zeit sich einmal zum vergleich wie groß
ich das jetzt ausgeräumt hab so was
ursprünglich und so groß ist es jetzt
dann nehme ich mir mein teig rädchen und
schneidet es etwa zwölf große stücke
etwa großen themen
und dann werden die jetzt einfach
aufgerollt und weil diese kartoffel für
ich davonlaufen kann müsst ihr die enden
hier auch nicht an drücken wenig aber
mit käse oder mit einer anderen führung
gefüllt die eben ausläuft würde ich hier
die enden schon an drücken
wenn ihr die forscher aufgerollt habt
müssen sie noch mal an einem warmen ort
gehen
das mache ich meistens im backofen so
etwa bei 40 grad
ich habe es leider vergessen mit filmen
wie es dann weitergeht
ich hab vergessen auf den knopf zu
drücken und zwar werden die brötchen
nachdem aufgeben dann noch mal mit einer
eigelb milch butter bestrichen so wie
eben bei meinen arsch mädchen auf und
danach werden sie bei etwa 200 grad 25
minuten gebacken
das kommt natürlich auch auf euren oben
drauf an ich backe bei ober und
unterhitze weil ich so das beste
ergebnis eben erziele ich habe meine
brötchen außerdem noch nachdem
bestreichen mit etwas regen und schwarz
gelber gestreut das könnt ihr natürlich
weglassen oder könntest auch ersetzen
durch andere körper ihr könnt zum
beispiel ganz gut gerade wenn ihr sie
mit kürbis wird auch kürbiskerne darauf
streuen schnitt sicherlich auch ganz gut
die brötchen auf jeden fall sie müssen
so eine goldbraune farbe haben und dann
können sie auch so sehen die brötchen
dann nach dem backen aus hier könnt ihr
ganz gut sehen dass ich hier diese
einzelnen schichten deutlich bemerkbar
machen
ich legte jetzt ein buch drüber um das
ganze ausdampfen und dann kann man sie
essen
jetzt wünsche ich viel spaß nachmachen
wünsche euch eine ganz schöne zeit und
an sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
bis bald